[Music] The
last topic I was discussing was talking
about young people who were suffering
under a 15-year permanent siege on the Gaza Strip.
I wanted to target the youth group and
link the idea of ​​the artistic work that I am
doing, which is recycling, with the fact that the
young man has become in need of recycling.  A recycling of dreams and
hopes, so that he can create new opportunities, so that
he can live and coexist inside the Gaza Strip.
[Music] For
us, there are needs, meaning scrap iron, but the
needs of this scrap iron we
make on the ground of reality, which becomes in
the world like a bag that we separate from iron, that talks about
immigration, and like a year.  Schools tell about school students and
their fatigue
[music]